hello everyone and welcome to another
incredible game from round four of this
year's London chess classic it is Hans
nean versus Shas Royale we've already
covered a game by Shas it was against
Thomas bson and it featured the Evans
Gambit so if you haven't seen that one
it uh will be the first link in the
description below quite a lovely game uh
but now let's get to this one but before
we check out the game I would just like
to mention a few things regarding the
previous video some of you said that
I've used a clickbait bait thumbnail for
the previous video because this was my
thumbnail and I it's sort of probably
just my imagination I I kind of thought
everyone knew what it meant and that you
know people just use Twitter as on
Twitter you can you know receive news
directly from the people who create the
news uh but the point of the thumbnail
was that um wesle so tweeted good
evening Anish and the point of the Tweet
was uh he saw gish's position and if
Gish wins this tournament he overtakes
both Wesley and Anish on the F circuit
list and he qualifies for the Fay
candidates tournament 2024 so Wesley
first tweeted good evening Anish with
the position that Gish currently had and
it was a winning position so that Wesley
said Tanish you know Anish we we're just
out of the out of the competition but
then after Gish blundered Anish
retweeted Wesley's tweet and he replied
good evening Wesley so saying that no we
are still very much in the game and
that's why I I I've shown you the game
with this thumbnail so that was the idea
uh if some of you actually thought that
this was some sort of a clickbait i
really had no no intention of doing that
uh it was actually very well planned out
or or so I thought so that's one thing I
wanted to mention the other thing some
of you have asked this in the comment
section why isn't Hans Neiman's rating
um updated for for December I have no
idea probably as the registration for
the tournament happened with the already
established rating from the month
November that's why it's still 2667 even
though on the live ratings list he's
actually
2695 uh point something but uh yeah okay
what are you going to do maybe in
January they updated maybe he will
already be
2700 but that being said let's check out
this very nice game we'll feature a very
nice pause the video moment for you so
Hans has the white pieces and he opened
with Pawn to E4 uh we have Pawn to E5
Knight of3 Knight to C6 and now Bishop
to C4 Shaz goes for Bishop to C5 and he
might have already had uh you know an
idea that Hans might also go for the
Evans Gambit like Thomas bson played
against him but no Hans goes for the
main line D3 the joke panimo of the of
the Joo piano uh we have Knight to F6
and now castles so all fa standard stuff
we have Pawn to D6 C3 and now A6 is sort
of the main line in castles but we have
Pawn to A5 stopping B4 uh and yeah sorry
about that uh and Rook to E1 and I
always mention when we have this
position because we have it quite a lot
it's the top main line of the Joo piano
uh why doesn't the black go Knight to G4
here and just try to punish this Rook D1
move because White's Rook would actually
be very well placed on E2 uh because uh
how does black continue let's say black
Castle he will play H3 so black will
also have to waste the tempo and once
black moves the Knight now you're just
going to play D4 and you don't have to
worry about G4 you've already played H3
with Tempo and The Rook is actually very
well placed on E2 as you'll see in the
game because in the game castles was
played we have Pawn to H3 stopping
Bishop G4 and now Pawn to H6 Knight beat
to D2 going for the standard maneuver
the Knight you know might come to F5 or
or H5 depending on what black plays
Bishop to E6 uh challenging the bishop
here and Bishop to B5 so this is all
again very standard stuff thousands of
games in the database uh when I say
thousands I mean probably like 120 uh so
Queen to B6 going for this maneuver
Queen to A7 putting pressure on D F2
pawn and Knight to F1 we have Queen to
A7 and now Hans plays Rook to e um the
top move play mve is Bishop to E3 Rook
to E2 is the second most play so
everything is perfectly fine here but
even if uh black did not force The Rook
on E2 in the other line that we've shown
The Rook still comes to E2 and it will
be perfectly fine here so here Pawn to
A4 freeing up the A5 Square for the
black queen to attack the bishop to
force a trade on C6 and hanos goes
Knight to G3 as I've said all been
played before H now there is a game
instead of this for example Knight to G3
move that D4 was played Peter Sidler
played against panov and theyre their
game but here Hans goes Knight to G3 we
have Queen to A5 and now captures on C6
we have B captures uh and now D4 can be
played here Bishop to D D2 can be played
here and also Rook to C2 as there aren't
that many games in the database I really
allowed the D engine to Crunch the
numbers here just to see how prepared
Hans was and indeed D4 uh Bishop to D2
and Rook to C2 are the three top engine
choices and the engine says yeah they're
all three are equally fine so Hans goes
for Rook to C2 and now uh there is a
game that Miguel Santos Ruiz played
against Nikita meshkov this year in um
Bundesliga uh in March where the game
continued with King to H7 but here we
have Rook F to B8 and it is now as of
move 15 that we have a completely new
game so a very very long theoretical
struggle uh and now uh what's the idea
how does Rook to B8 fight against Pawn
to D4 because Rook to C2 if if the
position opens up uh The Rook gains
control of the C fou the Double C Pawn
might be in trouble well the idea is
that if D4 Bishop to B6 and now you're
of course you're not going to open up
the C file for the white Rook so Hans
played Pawn to C4 he grabbed more space
here controls D5 and now shz goes for
Queen to B6 puts pressure on B2 but
mainly puts pressure on the F2 Pawn Hans
defends it Queen to E2 now King to H7 uh
we have Rook to B1 preparing that pawn
to B4 push whenever it becomes possible
Queen to A7 as you don't want your queen
on the same file as the white Rook here
and now Bishop to D2 again fighting for
that B4 Square we have Bishop to B6 and
now finally Pawn to B4 okay sh captures
it a captures on B3 alasa a captures on
B3 and now Pawn to C5 grabbing more
space here uh sort of weakening the D5
square but it's not really an issue you
don't imagine any of the knights here
reaching that D5 Square okay you could
play Knight F1 Knight to E3 Knight to D5
but you know from experience that this
Knight belongs on the king side controls
the F5 Square the other Knight comes to
H4 and then to F5 and you have some
lovely pressure against the black king
also one of the reasons sh play King to
H7 is to add more support so we don't
have to worry about all of these
sacrifices so here we have Knight to H4
Hans continues as one would in the Joko
piano and now Knight to G8 the Knight
again will be very useful here um uh
serving as a defender of the H6 pawn and
hun opens up the position with Pawn to
F4 and it's very nice that the position
is blocked here otherwise you would have
trouble opening up this diagonal so e
captures on F4 Bishop captures and now
Rook to E8 putting pressure on the on
the White Queen here indirectly sort of
X-Ring uh and now you have to decide do
you start grabbing hold of the f file or
do you play Bishop to D2 the move Hans
played sort of Shifting the bishop to
this diagonal and uh shiras has to
decide how to go about this he plays
Pawn to C6 he wants to play D5 and D4 to
close up this position or to get some
trades in the center which will also be
very good for him because he will open
up this diagonal so okay hun goes Knight
G to F5 and now we have Pawn to D5
striking in the center uh Bishop to C3
provoking D4 and Shas goes for it and uh
serves both ways to be honest um it does
take away this beautiful diagonal from
hans's Bishop but it does closes this
diagonal for the black queen and the
black Bishop so both this bishop and the
Queen Bishop combo will have to find um
uh you know their use on a different
diagonal so okay after D4 we have Bishop
back to D2 and now Bishop to C7 now you
can even even play something like Bishop
to B8 maybe Queen to C7 maybe put
pressure on the H2 Pawn or you you will
play uh you know put put a queen on B8
have a different kind of pressure all
depends on what Hans plays so he goes
Queen F3 and now Pawn to G6 just kicking
away the Knight and now the point is if
you go back let's say Knight to G3 then
Bishop to d8 is very annoying attacking
the Knight if the Knight comes to F5 now
you will play Queen to B8 and now once
B4 is played uh you don't care you're
you're just going to play Bishop back to
C7 more pressure here and you cannot
capture on C5 because the Rook is
undefended on B1 so you're going to play
B5 and now you will accept the Knight so
G captures Knight captures and after
let's say queen to d8 um you have to set
up some sort of a defensive perimeter
here Queen to H5 Queen to F6 defending
against everything on on H6 as the
bishop queen and the Knight are eyeing
it and now let's say Pawn to B6
attacking the bishop Bishop B8 and if
Rook to F1 you will simply move the
queen to G6 black defends and black will
win this game so that's the idea uh if
hunts just moves the Knight so hunt
doesn't move the Knight he plays Pawn to
G4 he goes after the black king uh and
that will most often be the case if you
try your hand at the Joko piano and now
after G4 Bishop to d8 uh now capturing
wouldn't be all that impressive if you
decided to capture now then the bishop
is out of the game and will be will be
very unpleasant with perfect play it's
still a draw but as I always say with
perfect play Everything is a draw so
Bishop to d8 by sh and now Knight back
to G2 uh we have G captures on F5 now sh
accepts the Knight sacrifice G captures
on F5 and Bishop back to C8 so now hunt
has to hurry up with the attack as all
of these pieces aren't really doing all
that much but if they get activated uh
the the extra piece will definitely mean
a whole lot so King to H1 Hans announces
the doubling of the Rooks on the G file
and you have to set up some sort of a
defense against the queen to E7 was
played uh now comes Rook to G1 we have
Bishop to C7 and now Queen to H5 now
putting pressure on the on the black
king and here uh well it's a very
unpleasant position but uh we have
Bishop to E5 and here hun is completely
winning but there is only one move that
forces uh uh the immediate win uh if you
miss it then black will be able to set
up a defense black will have enough time
so you know uh make use of the tempo
feel free to pause the video and win the
game for hunts while I give you a couple
of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on always
uh getting to the bottom uh of of every
position and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is Knight to
H4 and uh okay you probably realize why
you're going to go to F3 and then to G5
but uh even uh even the tactics are not
enough you have to you have to play it
now because let's say you play something
like ruby2 you prepare B4 you want to do
something once black plays Queen f8 and
defends the H6 Pawn with the queen then
the Knight can be activated and your
attack is gone now you play Knight to H4
doesn't matter just Knight to F6 and the
position holds the queen is attacked the
queen has to go back so Knight to H4
just in time so Knight to H4 and now uh
how do you play now Queen f8 uh is is
not enough if you play Queen to f8 now
then comes Knight to F3 and now Knight
to F6 attacking the queen just runs into
Knight to G5 check that's the problem
King to H or you go under the mask of
The Rook King to h8 and now you're going
to play Knight captures on F7 with check
and that's it you either give up the
queen or you go here and then Queen to
G6 is Checkmate so that's why the tempo
was was crucial there Rook to A7 was
played by Shas grabbing hold of the
seven Rank and now Knight back to F3
attacking the bishop but also going for
Knight to G5 check so Bishop to G7 and
now Bishop to F4 final Improvement
before uh you know putting that final
nail in the coffin we have Queen to f8
so sorry a bishop to f8 uh and now comes
Rook captures on G8 this is a beautiful
move as it sets up a double Rook
sacrifice so we're going to do it in
slow motion as we usually do and you
have to take the Rook otherwise you're
just down too much material and you're
going to get checkmated so King captur
and j8 now Rook to G2 with check and if
you go King to H7 the problem is after
Queen G4 there's no stopping Checkmate
you can't move the bishop so The Rook
controls G8 and uh you can't play this
because this is mate there's no move you
can make here so instead after Rook to G
Bishop the G7 was played but now Hans
sacrifices the other Rook as well Rook
captures on G7 King captures and now
Bishop captures on H6 with check where
you either get checkmated or you win the
black queen point is if King to G8 then
Queen to G4 check King to h8 and queen
to G7 will be Checkmate so after Bishop
captures on H6 uh King to H7 was played
but now you're under the mask of the
Queen Bishop to D7 and you win the black
queen king to G8 was played Bishop
captures on E7 Rook e captures on E7 and
now Pawn to F6 and he was in this
position on move 45 that shz roal
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here your Rook is
hanging but also you have bigger
problems here so if you decided to
continue the game just E5 and black has
zero moves here the bishop no moves Rook
no moves this Rook okay this Rook can
give a few checks maybe Rook A1 check
King G2 Rook A2 check but now you're
just getting checkmated whatever you
play let's say Rook D2 uh Queen H6 with
Queen to G7 Checkmate next Unstoppable
you could of course prolong it with some
silly moves but we don't show those kind
of moves on this channel yeah after F6
hun wins his first game of the London
chess classic so three draws then a win
and we'll see who he faces u in round
five or yeah we're not going to see I'm
going to tell you who he faces so let me
just check I was mostly focusing on
whoes will face but Hans in round five
will face Amin tabatabai and
interestingly for gkes it will be a very
very uh tough round because he faces the
leader of the tournament Michael Adams
is currently leading the tournament with
three out of four then we have three
people on two out of four GES Hans stean
andil Mard uh gkes faces the leader
Michael Adams and get this in the final
round gkes will face Hans nean uh so if
it's going to be you know up to the
final round whether gukesh qualifies for
the candidates tournament or not it will
be Hans Neeman standing between gukesh
and the candidates tournament uh which
is I mean more than we can ask for in in
a Chess World you know such such
excitement uh so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it very nice
showing by Hans by sh as well but even
though he played everything perfectly he
knew the theory he held his own for some
20 moves then he even got a better
position H but he just um uh wasn't able
to exploit it to its fullest and it was
enough for hunts to get an attack going
and then you know uh after that he was
merely uh using um uh you know the the
the provess of your of your combinations
to to take down your opponent uh so once
again hope you enjoyed it I would like
to thank David gasparian SE willamson
grn the maximite chess club and um uh
and the hogy boy uh on Spotify for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions uh and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
uh so thank you all I will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day
and I think it's actually pronounced
Huga boy so sorry about that uh see you
soon